just when we thought Camila Kibeho and
Shawn Mendes couldn't be any cuter they
one up to themselves she's amazing over
the weekend Camila was spotted at
Barclays Center in Brooklyn where her 21
year old rumored boyfriend performed two
nights in a row
but it's this moment that has everyone
talking that's a 22 year olds watching
Shawn on stage with real-life heart eyes
like come on if that's not the look of
love I don't know what is and it appears
the 21 year old singer was feeling the
love too because after the show he
shared a series of black-and-white pics
on Instagram writing in the caption that
there had been quote magic in Brooklyn
[Music]
the display of serious cuteness comes
ahead of the 2019 MTV VMAs where Camilla
and Sean are set to perform their sultry
track señorita together for the first
time of course Sean and Camilla have
been friends for years
no we are just friends where two times
we're not dating but after the release
of their sexy music video rumors started
swirling that the two were more than
just pals especially after they were
photographed on multiple PDA heavy
outings including Shawn's 21st birthday
party we're talking tonsil hockey in
public people a source recently told et
that the two are quote committed to
working on a relationship as she travels
with Sean on tour adding Sean and
Camilla originally were just enjoying
spending time together and having a
summer fling
Camilla had just got out of a
relationship and Shawn was in the middle
of a massive tour however Sean and
Camilla have really fallen for one
another this is just a match made in
music heaven and I am shipping for it of
course
et will be here to break down all the
details from their VMA performance so
make sure to keep it locked right here
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye
for now